you play with Gobots that is it that
little tangle that they're like want to
be transformers doing that [ __ ] up Nick
Goldmember those Gobots is nothing
sadder than watching a kid play with
booth leg training they weren't as cool
as transformers oh this is Decepticon
and here's you go bot Allen broccolini
get your life together touch me bro I'm
not touching
what are you guys doing caddy yells -
what's happening in the tech editor here
and show you think cap you worried about
Corona no here [ __ ] a blowout this
morning huh
looks like cat Yonsei yeah yeah what's
the occasion your helix oh nice
I had so much time to kill this morning
ever since Corona hit I've been waking
up at 6 o'clock in the morning on the
dot for no reason for you to it's I have
nothing to do I am going crazy caddy be
over yes I'm so bored
now does it make you want to get back in
a relationship because definitely people
started noticing how lonesome it is
around my place I got a plant yesterday
got a new plant both there's both sides
of the you know fence there because this
thing goes long in the past 30 days I
might kill a bit I thought about it I
might do again more and more like until
I keep doing this nicotine watching
[ __ ] Brokeback Mountain oh I saw you
running out routes the other day their
living room it's getting real
questionable where or if I can gate or
shirt the other day just I didn't know I
had one yeah man it's curly let me feel
weird I wonder what has me feeling like
I'm oh dude I'm telling you there's me
all right we go past April 30th I can't
all right I'm with my fullest life - I'm
hiking eating food like not late
Chappelle I'm just living my full life
no traffic
I Drive 120 miles an hour everywhere I
go I'm telling man after the 30th I'm
gonna [ __ ] bust out my the [ __ ] out
I'm a freak the [ __ ] down why you know
ejaculate somewhere yeah that too many
yeah wow yeah I guess I mean I didn't do
it yesterday I kind of took half the day
off it was a Monday so that was kind of
bizarre is like okay there's nothing to
do oh is AHRQ's on I'm I'll watch the
second season again do you do you wake
up I'll wake up my Mike what day is it
it's like every day's [ __ ] Saturday
yeah or Sun it's just like a real long
Sunday
enter your paranoid you the children get
paranoid does it feel like yesterday's
the first time he's like papa
my friends obviously you know Aiden and
blah blah blah I'm like what you can't
Papa I mean I told you about the
sickness going around he's like okay
Danny I know my damn sorry dude we keep
him busy kid people draw up kid draw a
picture of his family on line it was
like dad mom sister and then a picture
of like a little virus with it
but dude with speaking the dark a lot of
black people don't have it do you notice
that yeah celebrities don't count name
another one celebrities doing it for the
hustle Tom Hanks I'm out oh I got Corona
yeah wait Michael yo got it remember you
know he's half Chinese he looks like
he's had at that before also Allah yeah
I think he's had it just kind of
resurfaced yeah I matter it's like
athlete's foot
you know it'll come back I've had it
multiple times
yeah he said he got it and I I guess you
put a video about it I didn't see it but
I just get shocked when select when
celebrities get it to me it's like like
Kathy Griffin got it but she didn't get
it okay do you about to see me next week
I guess that Corona get my tickets oh
yeah Cincinnati Cleveland yeah I got a
mini muffin stuck in my throat
make sure you get my tickets I don't
know if I make it out of here online
right now just one sale new tour yeah
coffin to my coffin that's gonna be it
50 shades of deceased but yet howl it is
some are gonna be though oh yeah insane
guns bro imagine I mean dude there's so
I got two guns coming now two more guns
I'll shooting guns on son oh yeah I
think you sent me a picture you shoot
yeah we shooting they are shooting the
AR and I'll shooting that [ __ ] the
real uh the the John thick gun the
actual gun the trained Keanu Reeves
there and also they got an arm is this
you right here shoot that's me right
there John thick in the house now that
target is close
oh yeah we're not snipers [ __ ]
this is real life-like check out the
[ __ ] at the bottom no way that's what
they asked me to do Oh check that up yes
that's that mass shooter distance from
accomplished bro why do some of those
targets are carrying book bags and stuff
through this [ __ ] looks it's not ready
for mass shooting bro this is like one
of the shady laces to practice what's
that John thick right there bro dude we
could have redid tango and cash you come
up there uh yeah I'll get up there man
you love a knobby tango yeah yeah I'll
be cast do you want to dance hey are
they doing any uh is anyone in here
religious are they doing church services
right now they're just doing like
facetiming long livestream but still
taking donations still come to your
house asking for money like [ __ ] the
Lord is working overtime right now Lord
making Bank right huh I don't know what
they can't I know a lot of them they
can't do in person they did have uh here
you go
Tampa mega church pastor arrested after
a leading packed service despite safer
at home order pretty busy so if you want
but if you want to go get the Lord you
can go get I mean that's the thing if
you're gonna step out for the Lord
that's the only person you really gonna
step out from know you know you know
it's at right here but he's also
apparently over there often Billy Billy
is also in Tampa and also apparently is
in your bank account how the Lord costs
a little the Lord did you all be friends
with the Lord it's it's expensive man
how many it costs to print the Bible man
it does bucks it does so only got to pay
for it
[ __ ] man did you go to church as a kid
Jamel um my mom stopped taking us to
church cuz my brother and I got in a big
fight in front of the church yeah he
slammed me in the Cadillac damn body
Oh why were you guys fighting over the
Lord over John thirteen over John
13 church was boring and we would just
act out and then he just grab I grabbed
him by his neck and he slammed me to
this old dudes Cadillac and [ __ ] and too
embarrassing too embarrassing they got
those sports at the church too now yeah
you know sort of flag flag football yeah
tight tight they got fries and fast
action freeze tag too true the Lord
freeze tag as we call it yeah
Red Rover Red Rover Simmons big-ass
write-offs in the Lord right over those
kids would be nervous house yeah hold
hold
in the Lord's workmanlike juggernut I
can see that yeah yeah
Church can't was fun traditions one did
I remember painting a chair I painted a
chair at church camp
and that's thing is beautiful dude hey
they're kinds of paint they make the
kids work though right
we made a couple of chairs what else did
we do I go the activities a days
cleaning the church we sanded the pews
one time I do remember that Oh today's
activity were washing the pastor's truck
they would take us on walks and we'll
put us all like in these children
chained things really like kids together
in a line and like make them all walk
you know like it was definitely felt a
little what's going down I think there's
a lot of like you got a key they got one
lady to manage all the children so they
got a reindeer you know reindeer all in
the little like a robo-moe yeah yeah
yeah you know boy you got that fat
[ __ ] sister front leading the pack
and just all shining it to the horn
slices I don't know what to do man I was
go I don't know what was going I was up
I didn't go to church I went to my
summer camp was always at the YMCA which
is Christian affiliated you know so they
would like we play all Dave random [ __ ]
so much on yeah so much fun they just
dumped a bunch of balls in the middle of
[ __ ] grass man pull out it'd be like a
soccer ball a kickball football yeah
dude it would just be like a ball of
just uh
one of them was $1 the basketball you
know we're on grass but you know we'd
have fun with it they'd have a
basketball that somebody had drawn us
into a soccer ball like somebody had
drawn soccer you clearly took off white
yeah yeah so he dumped those balls and
then they're just basically wrangle us
up for about two or three hours out of
the Sun and then they'd give us orange
slices right and we'd eat that so the
kids are full of sugar then they try
giving us a [ __ ] Lord's Prayer like
where are the all these kids acting out
dude we just ain't 19 oranges you're
[ __ ] oh you're the only trying to
hear Jesus right now you're the only one
that ate 19 away I was hustling for
oranges I trade a lot of micromachines
trade super soakers dude we got in there
what they have we got that wean you got
that Frank lunch they'd have grilled
Franks over their wieners oh I'm so you
get that big win or at lunch
you got that footlong in your mouth and
the African again was trying not to
vomit it dude because in the afternoon
every ball turned into dodgeball like it
didn't matter is basketball soccer a
pool ball that I remember they had a
pool ball in there nothing better
yeah they had like a UH one of the
stripes in there did they make you swim
all the time huh oh yeah they make us it
was mandatory at two o'clock great to
swim all the time and me and my brother
[ __ ] hated it when you when you don't
want to swim there's not a worst
activity in the world so my brother goes
dude he's older than me right I was
always trying to like impress him
because you should [ __ ] in the pool and
we'll be able to get out of it that's
stupid
so on Wednesday at 2 o'clock I shook the
biggest [ __ ] in the pool and I I was a
hero for quite some time
my brother goes white [ __ ] and almost
someone what's my way and yell turd and
that's what we didn't go sounds like the
worst musical I've ever heard of him and
then our then our counselor had to get
that he had to get the net you know and
fish it out it had to drain the whole
pool man oh we're off for rest summer
really was a hero dude do you know some
other made you like oh that's insane man
no like you try sucking my dick
oh yeah YMCAs why do you know about them
the dark arts of YMCA bro that is
there's a lot daughter belly the YMCA
you think you've known you'd have no
idea there's a lot they don't put in the
fan plet yeah
I'm gonna say little Jerome you try
sucking your dick when you change your
clothes jump in the pool and then my
brothers come flying across the ropes
like Macho Man Randy average beat his
ass bro if somebody who'd the last
person's dick I'm gonna suck is the guy
who [ __ ] in the pool that's the dark
arts the YMCA bro it was [ __ ] awesome
got an Aurora non Aurora Colorado I went
to YMCA Camp and won a bike in a
Playstation there you go was that last
week Nick please Nick me in the
counselor
dude I was a counselor for a while yeah
I went to YMCA Camp for years and I was
a counselor did you go chin would you do
I've never done anything like that no
boys club did you ever exist anyway did
you guys go on field trips or just for
school it's like once settled very long
long but what about in the summer do
what about in the end they what'd you do
in the summer
we stayed home and play with our friends
oh did you play outside yeah in the
backyard outside with what would you
play gin you play with Gobots
gobots apart sure don't I know Brennan's
a GoBot if you put them in the pool if
you need someone holler at your boy man
is it that little chocolate they're like
want to be transformers bring that [ __ ]
up Nick go Meadows gobots is nothing
sadder than watching a kid play with
bootleg they weren't as cool as
transformers oh this is Decepticon and
here's your go bot Alan and they're at
war with GI Jim bootleg toys
closer to my age alright nevermind nah
man I should look at boot leg hmmm
teenage mutant ninja ninja Mouse's which
other hero in a hamster cage
Wow yeah well in the female summers what
do you got what if females do in the
summertime when you were a child we did
a lot of phone calls to boys that's
about it besides like watching them play
at the park watch a bunch of like really
short asian dudes try to play basketball
oh yeah nothing well Sam
until that fresh [ __ ] Jimmy Lin comes
along just check this [ __ ] out agent
that long asian hell yeah they did one
and only a chosen one yeah I don't know
German jamie-lynn Jersey he was poppin I
had that Jersey Linsanity you know do I
have to show them respect oh I love
seeing an asian just really just rise
above you know I celebrated all of it
all of it
beautiful dude I like watching a lot of
Mexican dudes play basketball they're
all wearing let's fun to church pain a
lot of family yeah
accents for whatever reason turns in a
rugby player old yeah 11 on seven hold
your stance everybody shirts off dude
one guy even takes his skin off you're
like a bunch of bad tattoos ah yeah
valbruno you [ __ ] Jolla bro
kick it up no more foam does everyone's
Tanith [ __ ] the basically purple no
dribbling to Walt's Hector 1 ball that's
30 takedown they should have Diggy's and
Nike cortezes you gotta respect you
though dog don't [ __ ] yeah thank you if
you get out of line
yeah the fouls are real fast the fellows
on the funeral at halftime the vows are
salt it straight up assaults man yeah
the foul then half tiny dream
Cortana yeah supercharges its horchata
MSE that's just you drinking it
hey horchata is just a thick Mexican
milkshake in it then boys stay on it
though it's good man I like some more
chato yeah well yeah these celebrities
getting this [ __ ] man this [ __ ] scenes
what do you think hey you know one
Mexican that has it Wow
Mexicans don't get sick maybe not
mmm-hmm dude that's pretty that what
about that and what how about this Japan
doesn't have it and like literally
skipped over Japan South Korea don't
have it they locked that [ __ ] down
Koreans man you've been scared of it
dude I'm not scared of it I just feel
bad for my grandma she's 83 years old
she can't see her great grandkids she's
sitting at home she's getting depressed
every time I talk to her she's plopped
down from the news she thinks it's
getting worse I don't see how that's
worse than her possibly catching Corona
and dying to be honest I'd rather have
her out living get her ass out where she
live at La Crosse Wisconsin my my family
they go and send some people send her a
dress we'll get people to break into our
house yeah her dress until I lock the
door you get real fun yeah how alarmed
is she gonna be when somebody shows up
dressed as a rat it would be take her
for a little beats or the stick I could
help so it's like China dude it's not
every mother okay but she's showing you
how the house they're on lockdown Selena
beat the [ __ ] out of her it's a stick
dude what how bad does she want to get
out not that bad man we're sending help
okay senator uber Nick hey yeah yeah I
don't know if she would leave the house
now she's scared he was around her 83rd
birthday just on March 22nd my just like
me my family she was on the first ever
edition of flaunt my aunt if you guys
recall do or not waking yet she had the
Texas said he's hurt his Chin's finance
system yeah oh no lack and white pitch
for that sister she's a diamond though
one of those cameras they got left
in the Sun when you're a kid and you
finally got the pictures development she
slit my dear
she price living both your dreams I know
she probably did actually I know she did
she slid into my Demilitarized Zone
what's that place called DMZ is that it
I thought it was gonna be a good joke
young we were when this show started
it wasn't like five years ago you have a
ponytail oh my God look the same this is
also the episode where Theo got a boner
in the middle of the table oh yeah
then Chin's on well they know I used to
give me an erection what when I sit in
an angle and talk to somebody at about a
50 degree angle I'll [ __ ] get here it
might be the a/c aren't those the chairs
we're sitting in now it is is it are you
hardship al the one I was in
Brendan's old chair you want this kind
of smells like Taco Bell oh yeah there's
definitely condiment in the cushions
he must are going reach you left if you
pull that lever for your legs dude that
Zeki sauce comes out the back you have
you pull the lever of [ __ ] capri-sun
shoots in your mouth do you know what
say yo you know it's a common issue that
fellow's face and don't speak of you
know what it is let me think let me
think long and thick hmm you're thinking
probably autism man but it's not 40% of
man by age 40 struggle from not being
able to get in maintain erection Oh bro
if I'm stressed out I'm 37 sometimes
that boy says we napping oh I said now
it's not the time that bro oh I haven't
had a naturally born erection in
probably a year and a half yeah that's
our seven years why are starting to just
they're not good man I need help go to
four hence comma one-stop-shop for hair
loss skin care sexual wellness for the
bros yup sometimes you got to pull up
the weenie baby and nobody does that
better than for hims
it's well known generic equivalents to
name-brand prescriptions to help you
combat erectile dysfunction yeah
connection a doctor it's so dang easy
answer a few questions with your medical
history a little doctor chat and guest
you get approved and the products are
shipped directly to your door and you
don't have to shoot it up a lot of
people old days used to have to freaking
hit that Lyle Alzado into the side of
you jump you hell more painful
injections or you go right down the
shoot hole oh no not anymore
try hymns today by starting out with a
free online visit go to forums calm such
J 80s 5 that's fo r hims dot-com / K 80s
5 for him calm / cats 5 C website for
full details and safety information
written this could cost hundreds if you
went in person in the doctor's office or
pharmacy don't do that man take the
loophole remember that's for hems comm /
k 80s 5 dang dude I'm sick of not
knowing what time it is I'm sick of
wearing this thing yeah I don't know
what it is anymore what I need is a dope
watch alright I need a really cool wide
oh yeah tell them yeah I need a
brand-new watch jumped on my MV MT
watches because I'm sick of just like I
look sometimes I'll go outside and I
don't know what's going on I'll have
breakfast in it'll be like 4 p.m. on
accident sometimes when I wear my
movement watch people when you look me
in the eyes anymore mm-hmm they just
talk to my walk really
yeah it's so aggravating I know it's
good looking and guess what it starts at
$95 that's right they cut out the
middleman starts at $95 okay sold almost
two million watches in over a hundred
sixty countries you look at $400 for the
same quality all right don't do that
don't do that give 50m stop today with
free shipping and free returns by going
to MVM t-dot-com /k ats movements
launching new styles on their site all
the time check out their latest movement
calm go - movement calm / k 80s join the
movement check out their latest at MVM
t.com / cats know what time it is we
want to hear some more names for our
friend Allison who was selling her
panties an online Chapelle has a list
yeah oh okay
oh we're trying to say make some money
yeah I only call it streaks are us oh no
I wouldn't get off the stairs there's
some better names on this letter names
dude written also ordered 40 pairs of
edible undies let me just try them all
when he was driving around this
chocolate what he got all right we got a
taco hammock or the cookie hammock make
you feel sick okay we got squirrel
covers monkey hammocks
oh that one taco hammock and the cookie
hammock was John from Canada and then ty
Hoffman over here with squirrel covers
monkey hammocks drip strips surf and
turf whoa yeah then Johnny Ramos came
through with the pantry oh the pantry is
good since homegirls name is Alison he
came up with Alice in Underland okay I
was hired and then uh he's got one more
he's got kitten snitchin okay and then
my favorite right here from Nick
Anderson rotten cotton calm you like
rotten condom shrieks streaks freaked
you out but rotten cogs cool yeah bro
Rob McCartney
do people want the front in the
paintings hidden what the back in there
what they want it all you don't know
your demo Satan worshipers creeps 1836
okay good come on and then Doug would
gave us a leftover lingerie oh I like
that
yeah I'd like a little more effort Eric
over here gave us chonies for the
bronies and he's got one more snail
trail apparel sale trail apparel we like
rhymes here
yeah it's clever streets yes streets
could be anything she thinks are us what
if somebody gets drunk behind a car for
a couple miles again
by car drug down the road streaks that's
his nickname streaks it would be if he
survived yeah okay Ryan Bennett we got
Beauty in the yeast party unless they
come at the back of a cookbook we gotta
go war Sam gave us Victoria's secretions
it's something that comes out of your
like usually a discharge or some type of
fluid like I kept a profession yeah they
kept it real pro there cuz very got real
dark yeah very scary how quick he knew
it unknown youtube comment commentary
snatching sniff I like that and then
Jason just kept it real nice and smooth
very arm be and he gave us Scent of a
Woman
mmm-hmm I like Scent of a Woman I like
the pantry I think was gonna cute it's
like not too on-the-nose you know um
literally because people gonna be
sniffing them scratching snow probably I
guess I think that's what they do with
them oh we believe you man you made all
those huh
you tell you friends years ago man yeah
man we anything is making this show
there's some good ones out there man
Allison underlaying that's really gross
and Underland probably the best that
might be good yeah and what was the
girl's name Allison Wow
oh and she she DM me to say I forget
she's not she's not in frozen wood what
else could she be in let's she's not
Cinderella oh she said it did she forget
she said she was a cast mate but she
didn't say what she did
she says she might said she's Minnie
Mouse hmm I could see that so what else
was we got some Gilders for then I think
look if you start the bombing can we
promote a business like this without
going to jail
I mean it's up to her right she's gonna
have to put the plan together you know
when a copyright
you can have streaks or us yeah we
release any and all of these to her yes
there you go girl
yeah good luck out there allison
Underland I think I mean I'll give you a
retweet will by Nick a pair yeah
definitely shared repos yeah if you get
out there yeah I might buy a few I think
you should have a front section in a
back section you know you could have
kind of the street section for Brenda
the full but yeah hole but undies what
else you got a cleaning lady let's move
on to some king under sting it oh yeah
this first one comes from Cody from
Myrtle Beach there's Brendan that's me
and you god damn that is a big time
that's doc annals son dude yeah
that's da cantle son right there Cody
annulled the tiger Whisperer himself can
you imagine no I can't nope not for me
that's you and your son dude years from
there years ago yes from now from your
book Cody handles killing it 1.9 million
videos of him the other day like
basically playing tic-tac-toe or
something with a mountain lion bro it's
unbelievable the stuff he's able to do
look at that man look Oh has he never
had an inch guys talk to him did he have
haven't even been bit by these Tigers
and [ __ ] doc and his son have never been
bit maybe yeah they said they've been
kind of like jostle around but never bit
he said they got to do yoga almost every
day in order for their bodies to be able
to like handle the weight of when these
animals come on come at him you know
relax but look at him though relax he's
agile Brennan that's called a John oh
yeah for sure you got to know about this
yeah yeah be pretty flexible to [ __ ]
with his Tigers I mean what did he just
ask us
even friends with start your Tigers King
understand I like to look at him would
you get in there it's kind of like being
a friends with Theo gotta be careful man
he's good in doses I'll say then he gets
dark you know second dude look I start I
start with a small ground game maybe
things you know that the baby hips
yeah dude them wrong all King it I guess
I don't know like would you go there and
hang out with his Tigers I would we
don't know him very well yeah agreed
so we're just gonna risk our lives Mike
yeah let's go hang out with this [ __ ]
tiger I'm not gonna give up with like
home girl who's clearly in the chicks
that lost their [ __ ] arm
yeah which probably helps her to hook up
with them girls do them you get that
conversation starts oh sure we got that
knob yeah there when you got that old
that you know when you're missing a
[ __ ] turn signal bro that's a
conversation just drive yeah yeah oh my
buddy stuff about like a cut-off arm
something and he would hide behind a
counter 45 well that's sad now that's
sad but damn watching him submarine
around behind the bar he get behind the
bar and just like it was like I bet he
got a lot of chicks doing that I don't
know
heated up with someone I knew that
though but what is that a submarine oh
my god let me keep drinking da cantle
did invite us out all out to his twenty
two person mansion where you can sleep
with monkeys and elephants and tigers so
if we want to do a little road trip and
you said like would you go there with
all the creepiness I mean there's too
much heat on them there they're gonna be
chill now they need good PR what creepy
I don't think he's creepy I just don't
trust these [ __ ] Tigers yeah I trust
doc and his son they're cool I don't
trust Tigers that are [ __ ] I'm not
trying to also I don't sleep with a
tiger why I'm allergic to cat are you
really yeah a saint a cat [ __ ]
that's exactly what
oh yeah ah dude you're allergic to
little [ __ ] ass cast that eat out of a
can brah this is a real hanim it's a
honey to [ __ ] bedroom mansion in
Florida
I said 22 person so probably I don't
know 10 Undertaker was just there last
week doing what try not to die just some
good PR I'm gonna say King in on the
Tigers man I say this if you got if you
die getting mauled I think that's the
way to go man
old school bet get back to the earth
quicker get back to the Lord I think if
you're out here just you know yeah you
allergic to some [ __ ] little cat
named Ronnie or something like that
brother how's that dude yeah [ __ ] that
man I'm trying to live I don't trust
these Tigers I don't know them I'm good
what what's the best-case scenario I'm
on the ground with a [ __ ] tiger worst
case hey it's how you it's not worth it
man I think that that's that that's the
chance you take man to be engaging with
your unique animals dude now what you
gonna spend your whole life just touch
them [ __ ] easy ass animals bro reach
for the stars do know I'm down to go to
Africa and see one in the wild
what's that real hitter that organic
Tiger hitters [ __ ] yeah I know so all
those [ __ ] Florida [ __ ] you look
like beef jerk
bro that thing's gonna see you you want
to go walk around I'm not walking bro
I'm in a safari you wouldn't want to do
King nothing arcing hissing wild and go
do a safari in Africa I wouldn't I would
his way weather right over to South
Carolina and practice Safari firsthand
the safe comfortable confines in
somebody's living room where they got
blow dart guns and a dude over there
who's you know able to they probably put
a bomb in the thing and if it goes off
they set off the bomb you know and I'd
be right it's just not for me I'm not
trying to ride over to Africa dude and
take my chances out there they'll kill
you in a heartbeat if you hang out with
Undertaker who's 90 years old and his
[ __ ] old lady and a tiger safe yeah
in the pool yeah dude you got your
goddamn money coming from the other [ __ ]
in the pool as a child dude you don't
even how to operate in these areas yeah
you're right what else you got Nick all
right I'm gonna king tigers but I'm
gonna sting hanging out with them all
right then I'll go in I'll hang out with
them what are you gonna do stand on the
side and what you face you face time no
you feel I'll be outside the door in
your face I want to be in there I'll
hunt a boar dude I've said this for
years people out there shooting a boar
from 2,000 yards give me a knife I'll
cut that fat thing's [ __ ] nose on the
killer's back
killer bees back let's get two knives
let's go work cut their noses off dude
that's what I'm saying I think it's fair
if you get out there and you hunt
something straight up me too yeah no
guns no heat-seeking missile just this
thing in a [ __ ] night yeah doing a
positive attitude why stabbing on the
third one [ __ ] yeah
I'd be down for that all right dude I
like it man gang bro what else got Nick
it's time for a rap battle we haven't
done this for a couple weeks and we got
some really good submissions oh yeah
first how come no black guys submit well
we initially called it white rappers
only so what about will my boy Dustin
Poirier submits Tony Ferguson coming up
saying dude you back on cocaine the
diamond yes I don't think you're gonna
give him that fight I don't think
they're I think they I don't think
didn't do the fight at all yeah it's
[ __ ] stupid
dude I was watching some Tony Ferguson
highlights oh wow do you never seen him
I've never seen it oh it's like he it's
like yes it's like his feet are like
knives made it's like it's like it's
crazy
ain't nobody want to short fight that
boy in short no that's crazy oh well the
diamond goes in right I'm telling you
nobody wants to fight that manager but
that's the thing about the diamond and
I'm telling you because I know what your
show it's a bad idea I'm not saying it's
the best idea but I'm saying that
because he needs a full camp if you give
diamond a full camp all right now we're
talking but short notice it's in two
weeks because weren't even training
right oh yeah right to fight Kebede
right here's a good chance to beat kabir
yeah the best short notice some of your
[ __ ] yeah ro and it would be Tony
Ferguson let's roll
got to go with that I just think I agree
with you but he's a guy who wants a
hangout Tiger so we'll take it
so last week with rap battle we had is
music he was the bigger gentleman with
Flo who said some inappropriate things
about Kat oh yeah oh yeah Johnny see the
angry bald gentleman who said the n-word
58 percent 42 percent I forgot the
n-word deals making t-shirts and where
they were hats and there were only two
of them that got bought and that was
years ago did sellout years ago years
ago he sold out of n hat but they used
it in the Asian community chin you guys
use it all the time the n-word Koreans
do but not that's not what it means
it's not black people it's just [ __ ]
and [ __ ] yeah and what does it mean oh
it's a wish as you [ __ ] me it sounds
so bad but that's just the way it is
it's crap I'm not surprised you guys say
it dude
I see how you guys it's Mexican to say
it to every now and then yeah imprisoned
Mexicans will say it all the time and I
think once you get into prison dude you
can make noises you already in prison
yeah it's only gonna get worse how low
can you go you know yeah I would get a
tattoo if I go to president says I do
not say the n-word on my back that's
smart
yeah just right out the gate and then in
the parenthesis unless you do well I
don't say it first
bro that's my role let's get into this
episode so then of course little brows
beat is music 83% oh yeah
to 17% but we got some really really
good submissions I can [ __ ] with little
brows oh I honestly believe it oh wow
it must be real man because you know put
your mother on you think you can put
your grandmother on it Nick we could do
a little duet probably put put is yard
now if your grandma says I quit don't do
that guys please don't do that I know
you would for the love of the show but
don't do that don't make it dumb I know
she's boarding house writing to help but
don't make her do yeah she's not that
bored she does not deserve that all
right what do we got here
yeah big gracias gracias
you should look denelle Gang Gang buzz
buzz recently conforto RIT Sun VC bro
Haywood have a rap for the king of the
rats and big brown in the bag bee sting
in that ass like a prison visit making
Chin behind glass that corner looking
that ethnic I think I love you Cassidy I
fell in love and now I'm changing my
ways I've been on pornog for like 70,000
ain't a mullet is a hockey haircut
Britain is slicked back looking like a
there's an estate the best place to
shoot roy bigot song rather the Komen
taking navigate like croak up
when he ate that third rounds punch
saving up my money I got 48 hun she's in
the LA Zoo here we come black blowing
three Oh meg Ryan mixed with Wang Chung
of Brendan beep price gum Derrick's
Morgan Freeman's son Nick looking like
he's never seen the Sun the Patels an
urban version of Kirsten Dunst and chin
is like a Clarence monkeys it's Pat you
are the one now let's lose these legs
highway 190 meter Tiffany Lane
yeah I'll be grounded okay you got that
CTE so we gotta drop a verse to for you
will de nada
here we go little hos nothing about this
fella now written looking dick where
you've been munching on some lunch traps
or some snack bags got a couple dozen in
your knapsack
but when it comes to big brown like you
[Music]
look like it's weird they decide to
shoot the whole thing in front of a
golden crown you ready for the hold on a
second real production face back
together
entertaining definitely more
entertaining know if it [ __ ] a little
browse though I don't know I'd have to
go back in and listen to that like I'll
do it after but not to go back in and
listen to that again man there's so much
in there let the fans decide but that's
pretty they call Chappelle [ __ ] urban
Kirstin bring it off Oh beautiful
yeah yeah you guys are both beautiful
piece that spider-mans girl Doug
well only they're blonde they had a
black spider-man what would that be
Hollis can be you Miles Morales oh wow
well he's black in Puerto Rican right
you talk about the cartoon yeah
spider-man verse yeah there was that big
movement to get childish gambino at one
point yeah you're supposed to do but
haters I hit me this next track he's
[ __ ] this is from wiser hip-hop now at
the warehouse at PacSun what's going on
[Laughter]
boy wiser like Brennan Theo taking brows
out the pic you saw segment getting
repo'd puffy burning head north or Reno
feel like Derek in the corner after
[Music]
slang a big shopping y'all at truckstops
but this is trying to hit I've been
smoking you wanna see me be oh my [ __ ]
just better plus I'll bet I got a better
hurry yes yo my we like diabetes but I
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like just a white man no boy the guests
sure like he looks like he's something
more than just yeah there's something
else going on there well they look like
beautiful young people men are beautiful
young they're you know these are young
men and women it's more like Chin's race
than you know yeah you can't even you
got a uh that's not right that's it dude
Asian people and white people look
different than each other Brendan when
he looks he looks like Theo than me no
he looks like chin but with sammy sosa
lotion like he's really white wonder
like chins face and facial hair he looks
pretty I mean he looks like a white God
and me look like a decent white boy is
he white and outdoors probably a
sometime the rest of his squad is white
maybe is and I like when they came up
with
krispy hit her with the mask right there
dude like Nellie's boy yeah oh that's
like Nellie's little buddy [ __ ] uh or
they call mask a dactyl that always
showed up the st. lunatics yeah it's one
had a mass one had the [ __ ] band-aid
yeah wasn't terrible Weiser that's what
they're called mm-hmm the heading was
good and that's somehow some video hoes
to both them are those the only two NIC
I heard it for this week I mean we have
week we could do this an entire episode
we got submission well I give to you
your raps no geez what do you guys think
kat-chan it's to me that it's different
than the little browse little browsers
like straight-up like rap battle this is
like more production editing like I
think lil brows has a video coming with
his he did that remix version and on
Friday he's trying to get back in the
studio and do a video for it so there's
more common but yeah I don't know we've
kind of really built up lowbrow so I
think we were like influence some of the
voting I think his talent does it too
though yeah a little brows beater I
remember I've woken up in the middle of
the night and had a little brow [ __ ]
going on in my head yeah my stand up I
walk out the little Browns remix damn
crowd goes crunk they do yeah but these
guys are these I thought that that both
of these are really great both these are
really good I just feel like they're
different it's more like these two are
competing against each other then little
brows that first one might be my
favorite actual song of the whole time
like it'd just so many references that
go way deep into both show they're both
so good both of the great shout to both
yeah I don't even know what to think or
say or do anything work it's a lot of
work to do those yeah it's just amazing
that these guys that these guys and
girls did this well the girls kind of
sat down at a good time but thank you
Kirsten we gotta stay alive bro that's
what I'm thinking about right now do we
try the Tigers in sure that was my whole
point with the Tigers I wanna stay alive
but you have to also live them
reduced ok we're hitting Lane dude what
do you want to do stay a lot ok and live
so what do you mean by we are stay alive
I'm saying what you said if you stay a
lot then you have to also get out there
and do stuff ok so what's your point
dude you're worried we're gonna die
no I'm just worried that we have to do
our best dang it you don't know what
you're talking about
well yeah we'll put it on the gram so
you will move on to some debate club
yeah let's move on
they were good though oh those guys are
great man
and here's this guy due to how they've
been doing drugs at home bro you should
only know that because I'm done that's
how I look yeah also this muhfucka ain't
gonna last minute 30 days to court yes
you really lost himself Rory Scovel did
one movies Amy Schumer nice losses
[ __ ] money it's Jordan out here in
Denver Colorado
sure it is we're quarantined working
from home lucky to have that option amen
brother
I'm not lucky to not have cut my hair
right beforehand coz barber shops are
closed up for another four weeks so I
don't know what I'm gonna do about this
situation but it's my new normal until
April 30th so in the meantime I got a
debate club question for you better
documentary tiger king or making a
murderer let me know what you guys think
shout out Nick Davis LT Darsh Gang Gang
buzzbuzz buzzbuzz 5280 club right there
baby
I'm hometown sweetie man I'm gonna go
with making a murderer
I think Tiger king hit at the exact time
or in quarantine it's good but if you're
going back watch his second time oh yeah
be honest I'm sick of these [ __ ] tire
thirst traps man these altmer fuck-ups
Omer Fonseca everybody jump on their
nuts I was on their nuts last we come
off now I can't stand Tigers I don't
play with you Tigers make it a versatile
make it no [ __ ]
the guy [ __ ] killed a woman that took
pictures of vehicles dude I wouldn't
call it some real [ __ ] okay what do you
think Tiger King is the tiger King is a
homosexual Clint Eastwood okay who has
one working leg and the other is a dick
with an e on it yeah because he shot
himself in the leg okay you know mainly
it is to tell everybody to look
everybody in the eyes and then shoot
yourself in your own [ __ ] leg to
prove a point
time and time again dude oh thanks dude
hey dudes do not imagine how crazy bro
just the level of just constant just
turmoil you've set up in your own life
you wake up you have to deal with 40 60
70 880 Tigers or snipers a bucket or
three you're having tiger for lunch
brother so many [ __ ] if you don't
stress joys all the yeah and then a
go/no to go into a gift shop and
comfortably sell a hat or a joe exotic
sponge or somewhere your employee got
their arm ripped I didn't get a full
refund
you know go through all that then
finally you get home and you have two
husbands and either the only the only
thing cooked for dinner is drugs and you
gotta go to then you go do an episode of
Joe exotic TV wake up do it all again
the next day I do a podcast at 6 p.m. oh
that [ __ ] you just went through yeah
he's a Leonardo DiCaprio on the second
Vince in the one side piece that he's
really gay every day I spit game on him
cuz he wants chicks you reading books to
me you've subbed out all the words and
put in gay of commitment that Joe exotic
had no his on my question his work ethic
okay
I'm not doing that okay I'm not doing
that that's what I'm worried about
you're doing no I'm not doing that his
work ethic is second to none I can turn
on second to none you see him in all the
videos he's helping load this load this
cat she don't I'm saying put this
lota somebody's ass somebody that's all
he's always trying to do is load some
boys asses up dude I'm not buying it man
I'm sick of joy exactly how about [ __ ]
Joe I'm not freeing that you should do
all 22 years with
killing all them [ __ ] Tigers damn
you're off the train bro [ __ ] tiger
on my face wow man
I'm an but who so what training you on
then you're on the train of a guy who
went to jail for murder got out and then
murdered somebody else dude you're the
jail for Steven Avery I better show
I just think making a murderer is more
quality as far as a documentary I think
Dan Hernandez one was better I think Joe
exotic kid at the right [ __ ] time
well I agree people are awesome nothing
to do worked cage that we are caged
animals right now something people can
relate on an innate level but I guess
good and you got it you got some find it
on the inner and then you find out he's
not really singing them songs don't
think what's what's real was he really
gay all these question is gayness do you
always see those songs I do know now
that he did not sing the songs but I'm
not shocked he didn't because he was
lip-syncing the entire time it's
blatantly obvious he was lip-syncing why
do you know how some people he's saying
it is non gay husband's funeral dude
he's on meth huh these are method yeah
sit still
what imagine doing all of that and
having to do math dude yeah and then
also manage four hundred Tigers yeah I
can I get what you're saying you give a
good argument man I'm saying for my
money you've seen the devil next door oh
dude you start living bro [ __ ] to do
go on Netflix and watch a devil next
door about a Nazi concentration camp guy
he's the main one Ivan the Terrible put
all the Jews in the [ __ ] gas chamber
horrible man yep and then they [ __ ]
find him the fan oh he's living in
Cleveland and they [ __ ] deport his
ass back to Israel he goes on real goes
on trial did he do it is it definitely
him well I don't spoil it do they
23andme him no way Wow
at Arriba that shit's more real than
he's [ __ ] who gives a [ __ ] about the
Tigers this goes back to the poll that
uh Theo threw out last week
is Joe exotic actually gay what people
say
38% think it's drug-induced
homosexuality they men what's the rest
sixty-two percent or ignorance you don't
have a mullet and grow up the roots with
a blonde and that's ugh dick that boy is
so gay
well but here's the thing you do enough
drugs you're gay man I grew up by a Bob
behind a rest area like across a river
from a rest area sure and a lot of gay
men used to meet up along side of the
interstate mysterious yeah I still do
and they were fine everybody was fine
they'd show up with their families at
first and stuff and then the families
would leave drugs would come then the
men were gay so it was like a
progression airy thing you've seen it in
the hobby shop Tina I bet 110 times so
you have a good case study oh it's facts
man so at a certain point it's fact so
I'm saying nobody's gay until enough
drugs is in the scene and then
everybody's gay you're gonna have it you
do anything to get that hit again yeah
you know if you tell somebody you know
hey I hit a little bit of meth in my
wiener you know get it out yeah there's
only one way to get out yeah so you
gotta it's magic bro it's just a certain
type of magic to get it wet here we got
a guy right here we got captain Lou
albano son right here coming in to us
we'll close it out with this great
debate club
I think he paid time by the way I got
some heatwave incorporated out there
twink when did you make that video they
doing this in Corona Times
I hope they don't give a [ __ ] dude the
part where we started Corona dude and I
hope that make a new strand bro me too
you know we need a string that people
can have and still go out and party and
work that's what you're talking about
um lifted trucks listen I like lifted
trucks I had a lifted truck just a year
ago here's thing about but they're
talking high rider or low rider bridge
you might thing about lifted trucks
though there's nothing worse than shows
that you have a little [ __ ] when you put
you know when they get lifted trucks let
me put the fake balls on the Mac I hate
that [ __ ] really I can't stand it the
nuts are just dangling your traffic just
there dangling and lowriders don't make
sense there's anything more Mexican than
a lowrider truck mm-hmm is very
distinctively Latino let you know
strictly yeah I think it's dope i like
it but ok well that lifted - hitter on
that left this dude on the left
you getting [ __ ] on the right you
getting homies yeah well I don't know
dude they got a lot of [ __ ] die-hard
Latin [ __ ] out there dawg you know
I'm talking about some real [ __ ] dog
that are [ __ ] yeah they'll suck on
your frijoles bro if you have that
[ __ ] lowrider no ladder home
mirror the magazine lowrider used to
have the baddest [ __ ] yeah on these
lowriders well then ok so that's what
you're saying right now then you know
that's not dude you get them little
[ __ ] 20-inch [ __ ] hitter bunnies
that jump in those trucks those lifted
monster trucks and it's low so a big
girl can even get in the back if it's a
right you're fed us no it's not oh you
gotta have a lean Jean you know a lean
Janet to climb up into that lifted truck
see a big girl try to get that lifted
thing it's your wobble off yeah I do
know big [ __ ] allowed catch a 38 to
the arm bro she'll catch it one of those
big tires will roll right over yeah but
you gotta have that Serena Williams
[ __ ] backside to jump up in that
[ __ ] truck yeah bad [ __ ] only
really oh I think that's a good look the
lower truck you can have more women can
get into the lower truck and short
homies yeah it's accessible oh yeah and
that's definitely I mean it's five for
Nation bro you're Mexican I'm I'm more
of a lift a truck guy myself but mitt
lifted truck you can go out there you
can park you can fish off of the back
you can hide stuff from people that are
short now here's one thing about a
lifted truck though they don't grow that
fast I'll lift a truck will top out
sometimes at 60 miles an hour you'd be
surprised then boys put on the
supercharger they put on different
pulleys cane and air filter that thing
gets moving my brother-in-law do yanti
lifts everything I mean he's lifted
everything they've ever owned dude I
mean they have a coffee pot in its own
[ __ ] sevens yeah so I think in my
side of the tracks dude I'm still on the
lifted side but I could be tempted oh I
believe I do believe the shorter that
lower vehicle is a better way to catch a
chicas yes I'm lifted on the female
humans yeah I feel you
well they say that 75% said lifted
trucks okay so we have 25 percent Latino
following yeah viva la revolución you
know what I'm saying yeah that lowrider
magazine though bring up some of those
covers Nick they're the baddest [ __ ]
mamacita's on there was a kid I get oh
yeah - ass off in Tatas bro the mom
Mexican teats on us boobies nothing but
oh my god the girl was on the cover of
one
oh you ain't ready for that you don't
know you know [ __ ] hot that headlamp
is - put your arm right nice dog you
know nothing about Vita in that perfect
o seekers
look at these both sides they lecture
you feel me tits you feel me daddy I'm
[ __ ] Mexican it hard dude I'll
[ __ ] pull my [ __ ] quarter-sawn out
and beat someone over the head with it
do don't give a [ __ ] bro you know what
I'm saying dude I'll [ __ ] sneak
across the border and sneak back across
[ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] did I
plant a garden but I don't give a damn
dawg [ __ ] I'll drop by the Alamo
and shoot into that [ __ ] bro oh yeah
and stay at a [ __ ] bays in for 11
months dude 13 of my friends all work at
the same place Wow dude good music or
Papa dude you look like the gayest
president of a biker gang called the
fondles
[Laughter]
biker jackets got the fondled he's sick
we fall off the [ __ ] wagon here yeah
that it Nick I don't know what we're
doing anymore that's it Jesus man we're
Jenna Dunn in the corona times dude
mm-hmm yeah first I was a little bit I
was like should we still be meeting up
but you know Mike the only thing we have
to do yeah what else we gonna do I would
go insane if I didn't have this I'd go
crazy
yeah but you have other shows to do yeah
we have to do all of them yeah ones by
myself it is yeah - hey Matty - talk to
me like camera is it really yeah oh my
god bro that's great
that's crazy but I can't believe man who
should it be over she got you through 30
days yes Melanie in keep your clothes on
it's not making afraid there's a
quarantine yeah tighten up take care of
yourself man do some back flips or what
work on your cheers bro yeah dude I got
no we're gonna form work on your form
you feel really good you still got it
when's the last time you did a backflip
too long you ask me long okay Mike
riding a bike
yeah do I feel like I'm gonna forget my
set really yeah oh I hope I forget mine
[ __ ] yeah shoot yours I know so you ever
hope you don't forget it that's true
yeah I don't know I wonder what they cuz
how are they gonna let I mean they're
gonna have to have a certain number of
weeks where nobody gets it what do you
mean they're gonna have like two weeks
where nobody gets the virus that's what
happened this month hopefully she'll see
that peak right now and think it's going
down but then what if [ __ ] two people
come out with it in [ __ ] November
then what happens you keep rolling as
long as they have no underlying I say
choke them out bro if they get it at a
certain point we got to take the people
that have it and put them out into the
streets into Florida yeah so into San
Pedro
put him in that GW exotic zoo over there
dude that's what I'm cinnamon Oklahoma
bro let the tiger sniff em out bro
that's what I'm saying put these people
in a place where people can go visit
them that love them but then also the
rest of us can live our lives man
you know if that's just you know you
rolled sevens bro you know and that
ain't all everybody's fault if I come
down with something it ain't y'all's
fault
you know it's my fault so I'm yeah I'm
so not scared of Corona if you got it
feel I'd still come in and do the show
you wouldn't yes that's where I'm at Wow
would you wear a mass oh yeah nope [ __ ]
it yes you two wear masks gang bro I
appreciate that I'd wear it yeah man
that's it give me your dates all right
I'll be no date the food to food I'll be
nowhere made to lose I'm good right
before you saw me eating yeah you're
right sorry mouth yeah we got nothing i
got nothing
I'm happy to be alive over but he's
doing well out there great submissions
to man the rap videos were insane yeah I
think this might be the best mission
ever got from top to bottom king of
sting it debate the rap videos yeah it's
just crazy when people are off this
episode we're being Theo no I'm just
kidding yeah thank you guys love you
guys love you guys man
Brendan and Theo fighter and wait I
gotta go in and go hard in the paint I
do not think I am and Flo black rifle
coffee I'm ready to go I need a sponsor
I am a monster about to open up with
this at my concerts Flo is contagious
browser outrageous thicker than girls
leather Instagram famous damn movie like
I'm fresh off keto see a red like Andrew
Santino right every Sunday is like the
great Bambino I'm 1/8 the case oh and
the case Cerritos but everything's gonna
be fine
hey Tommy I got a pack of matches in his
pockets at all times
they sliding into my DMS a couple of you
try to couldn't beat him quit playin
like that's in DoDEA's you don't want
the smoke like Joey Diaz meaning y'all
edible just got my eyebrows threaded and
I'm feeling an incredible grit and Sun
him me up he said it's too loud in the
club can you pick me
King in the state oh yeah Cain in the
sting bee sting Rat King
indistinct ain't enough steam gotta be
got the cheese on a string
as a sting King and the stinking
indistinct bee sting Rat King
and a stinking anesthesia that cheese on
the stream Brendan and do fighter in
Creole shout out New Orleans and shout
out to Co Colorado more specifically
Boulder Brendan came in with a chip on
his shoulder but is still gold and yet
it still fire if you don't like King
Aniston you're a liar Brenda's got like
a thousand different hustles one of
them's at Nordstrom Rack to win tie
yours black rifle coffee we hear you
loud and clear your son on the email
like please get me out of here is way
too loud in here watching the Irishman
eating pizzas drinking half a beer now
on the Theo von looking like the type of
dude there's a Rita songs
smoking cigarettes for the snapback on
let's a hit the craven turn snapchat on
it's all go we still mess with you 18:11
Pico Boulevard go get ahead Derek and
cat
y'all doing great Thursday upload not a
minute late y'all wanted to rap ahead a
demonstrate brand new studio y'all
feelin great putting Chris Delano in
this place now let's go and get you a
painting
and the sting bee sting crack
oh yeah King and then stay
traffic gotta cheese on a street dog is
a sting a king in the sting king in the
sting bee sting Rat King
and the sting a king and a sting gotta
beez in the trap gotta cheese on a
string
[Music]